vous avez indiqué que vous ne
participiez pas des campagnes politiques
en revanche la presse monsieur
takieddine takieddine s'est s'est
longuement
penché sur votre rôle pendant la
campagne électorale du président macron
notamment et donc la presse évoque le
fait que vous avez comparé les
prestataires possible pour le
développement d'un site internet de
campagne
avez vous effectué donc des missions
dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle et quel est votre rôle
est dans le think tank en temps réel
dont vous êtes membre du conseil
d'administration
plus généralement
une vingtaine de toujours dans la même
dans la même veine une vingtaine de
salariés
de votre société aurait participé donc à
7 cette campagne comment avez vous
assurez les règles liées aux conflits
d'intérêts et est ce que ses prestations
au figuré sur les comptes de campagne je
rappelle que 1,2 de vos
salariés et a été très rapidement
directeur de cabinet du ministre
mahjoubi donc apparemment il ya quand
même des liens assez assez fort entre
votre votre cabinet et la campagne
présidentielle merci
madame la sénatrice jeu répondra en
trois temps déjà je le répète c'est vrai
que nos statuts nous interdisent de
travailler ce soit à titre clients ou en
pro bono pour des organisations
politiques ou des hommes politiques pour
nous ne le faisons pas nous ne l'avons
jamais fait nous ne ferons jamais
ensuite comme vous le savez la loi
française est extrêmement protectrice
des libertés individuelles de chacun
pourra participer à des activités
politiques associatives ou collectif et
donc moi en tant qu'employeur je ne suis
pas habilité ne serait-ce qu'à demander
à une personne et elle exerce des
activités ou une implication politique
donc à ce titre je suis pas en état mois
de pouvoir les mêmes
serait ce pouvoir donner des
instructions dans un sens ou dans
l'autre par rapport une activité
politique et relève que registre
individuel puisque la question doit
aussi poser à titre individuel depuis ma
vie d'étudiant j'ai toujours considéré
que la côté de mon activité
professionnelle je souhaitais avoir des
activités associatives au profit du
collectif donc j'ai participé à travers
ma vie effectivement à des associations
notamment temps réel que vous mentionnez
et j'ai pu y avoir aussi des activités à
titre strictement personnel de nature
politique et
nous nous entendons bien je crois cette
liberté fondamentale de chacun de
s'engager à côté de ses activités
professionnelles
cependant il faut que ces choses là
puissent être contrôlés évidemment donc
votre réponse suppose-t-elle que vous
avez les moyens du contrôle de
l'application horaires de vos salariés
pour garantir que côte ils sont sur le
type d'activité donc parés à madame la
sénatrice goulet ils ne sont pas dans le
cadre de leurs occupations
professionnelles
oui bien sûr monsieur le président est à
préciser la condition de cette liberté
individuelle et bien sûr de ne cultiver
en aucune manière les ressources
collectives de notre institution et que
l'engagement soit fait en dehors du
cadre professionnel et tient aussi à
souligner en devoirs et respectent
strictement les obligations de
confidentialité
à l'égard des projets qui peuvent être
conduits comment l'avez vous avez raison
monsieur près comment est-ce que vous
contrôlez contre concrètement la bonne
application de ce principe tout à fait
sain par ailleurs nous pouvons contrôler
l'usagé des moyens vont été mis à
disposition par maclean's et à
l'intention de ses salariés
bien
[Musique]